how is it that harry potter went from
loathing professor severus snape to
giving his son the middle name severus
snape is arguably one of the most
conflicting and significant characters
in the harry potter series while on the
surface it may seem that he transformed
from the villainous potions master to
one of the greatest protectors of the
boy who lived the truth is he was always
on harry's side snape was cunning and
clever leaving a trail of very subtle
evidence that proved which team he was
on it may have taken a long time but
there was one special moment that made
us fall in love with the professor and
joined team snape forever let's have a
look
mr potter
our new
celebrity
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
introduced severus snape the dark and
broody professor between his appearance
and obvious disdain for harry which he
made no secret of from the very first
potions class both harry and audiences
presumed their relationship was to be
contemptuous we would think that the two
would keep their distance neither being
a fan of the other so it came as a
surprise when snape had his eye on harry
while he played his first quidditch
match that particular match was one of
the many occasions that potter found
himself in danger as his broom began to
cause him trouble sharp-eyed hermione
was quick to notice snape staring and
muttering at harry knowing the hostility
between them it was safe to assume the
professor was trying to cause harm this
was one of the many moments that there
was more to the story than we were able
to see he further showed us his
intentions by acting as the referee for
the next quidditch match to make sure
harry was safe there was nothing for the
potions master to gain from helping
harry yet he took the risk to try to
reverse the jinx placed on harry's broom
anyway he never looked for thanks only
to protect harry i don't want me as your
enemy quarrel
so often professor snape was condemned
as the villain distracting harry ron and
hermione from who they really should
have been looking out for being young
and taking snape at face value the three
gryffindors assumed the professor was
trying to steal the philosopher's stone
after discovering the truth that he was
only continuing to protect it and stop
it from ending up in the wrong person's
hands the three still didn't trust him
that was no strange accurate village it
was snake snape also never made it a
goal to earn their trust he simply did
what he thought was best to protect them
at first glance it seems to us that
snape would rather be anything but a
professor the way he speaks about the
students that aren't part of slytherin
house leads us to believe that he
doesn't care what comes of the rest of
them why would we think he was rooting
for any of the students to succeed it
only became evident to us later that the
opposite was true snape was canny in his
ability to teach harry and his friends
the lessons he knew could help them an
excellent suggestion professor snape
while the potions masters methods may
have been unconventional at times we
can't ignore the fact that his skilled
judgment is what allowed him to teach
harry who consistently resisted despite
our initial judgment we understand that
the professor always made sure to teach
not only the potions curriculum but the
practical skills harry ron and hermione
needed to survive and thrive at hogwarts
out for a little walk in the moonlight
are we let's think about harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban snape
finally had his chance to take on the
defense against the dark arts class
while lupin was on leave while he was
teaching he insisted the students learn
about werewolves and tried to instill
the knowledge he felt they needed this
was all to benefit harry and his friends
so they were better equipped to handle
lupin we begin to see here how creative
snape was in his teachings in harry
potter and the order of the phoenix
professor snape played the role of both
potions master and occlumency tutor for
harry in these lessons i will attempt to
penetrate your mind throughout the year
snape pushed and tested harry which
didn't help their relationship at all
the young wizard wasn't able to let go
of his distrust and distaste for his
enemy while snape's harsh methods may
have seemed like an opportunity to
ridicule harry we understood after the
fact that the professor was only working
to ensure the young wizard had the
strength to protect himself from
baltimore though these lessons were only
somewhat successful snape provided harry
with the important information and
advice that would help him along the way
refusing to let harry be without
information that could protect him we
can understand why he was so tough on
the boy who lived we are hardest on
those we love after all harry had many
mentors in all shapes and forms one of
the most significant in his later years
was definitely the half-blood prince the
knowledge that came from the old potions
book was instrumental in his success at
hogwarts that year and proved useful
beyond the classroom this was perhaps
the only time that snape ever took
credit for his secret teachings when at
the end of the year he revealed that he
was in fact
this also helped us to recognize how
masterful a wizard's snape was
indicating to us that there was more
than met the eye when it came to the
so-called villain if we consider the
many many jewels harry was battled in
his signature spell was
it's quite extraordinary to think of how
many times this spell saved the wizard
this spell was with him from the very
beginning of his time at hogwarts and
was the one he was passionate about
teaching when he was running
dumbledore's army it's no coincidence
that the one who taught him this spell
was his greatest protector professor
snape strikes again
professor snape was deceivingly loyal to
many and truly loyal to one harry the
potions master did not hold back in
showing his true allegiance when
professor umbridge tried to get the
truth out of harry by using vera to
serum truth serum it came as a surprise
to everyone that snape told umbridge
they had run out he also went so far as
to publicly state that the last of it
had likely been used on cho chang
clearing her name of betrayal to harry
and the rest of dumbledore's army this
is an ideal example of the subtle ways
snape showed kindness and compassion
proving he was looking out for harry and
secretly on his side what is he talking
about snape
no idea
in this moment we recognized one of the
ways the professor was risking his
reputation by overtly lying to a fellow
staff member it also allowed us to see
the fervent attention he paid to harry's
personal life a notable consideration on
top of all he was doing to keep harry
safe the double agent went to great
lengths to keep up his appearance as a
villain severus
come
we've saved you a seat
this was particularly tricky when he was
dealing with the true villains snape
spent plenty of time with the
notoriously evil bellatrix lestrange as
he had her convinced that they were on
the same team first he fooled her with a
replica of the sword of gryffindor a
tricky feat for sure but not compared to
what was to come he put his own life at
risk by making an unbreakable vow with
narcissa malfoy to convince her and
bellatrix that he was on voldemort's
side this was a wickedly dangerous
commitment snape quite literally putting
his life on the line it helped the
professor to earn their trust and keep
up his facade to think this moment was
one of the countless times the potions
master risked being caught in his game
of deceit is remarkable it isn't lost on
us that the professor spent years of his
life regularly duping the most
villainous wizard in history the bravery
he showed in his pursuit to protect
harry definitely gained our trust and
earned him a spot in our hearts while
professor snape often tried to protect
and help harry by teaching him there
were some times so dire his only option
was to physically protect the boy who
lived snape had a keen eye and when he
noticed that professor lupin hadn't
taken the wolf spain potion he
immediately sought out to find the
students
the potions master swept in just in time
as lupin had transformed into a werewolf
and was ready to attack snape quite
literally stood in the face of danger
shielding the students to protect them
out of character as it may have seemed
it was more true to who he really was
while we may have had our doubts about
snape it was hard for us to ignore such
a valiant act and helped us to see the
good in the professor
while harry continued to distrust snape
the professor always stood his ground
and kept the young wizard's best
interests at the forefront of his mind
after harry is witness to snape ending
dumbledore's life he runs after snape
furiously when harry confronts him
bellatrix goes in for the attack snape
stops her by giving the excuse that he
belongs to the dark lord another clever
way he protected the boy who lived in
the immediate face of danger evidently
harry didn't think this was proof enough
of his loyalty and insisted snape fight
back as he repeatedly cast spells after
all the professor had done to protect
harry this was undoubtedly a trying
moment for him we recognize here how big
a person he was to continue to falsely
act as the villain in order to keep the
wizards safe
when harry was struggling to destroy the
horcruxes little did he know snape was
lurking in the shadows as he often did
through a beautiful and sentimental act
snape managed to lead harry to the sword
at the bottom of the lake with the doe
patronus even though he seemed to not
want to know harry he is likely one of
the people who knew him best we can't
ignore the skill it took snape to pull
off such a tricky task clearly showing
us snape's expertise and profound
personal connection to harry after
seeing this we can't deny he was a
virtuous and valiant man
once harry had a chance to peer into
snape's memories of hogwarts his
consistent dislike for the boy who lived
finally began to make sense after being
relentlessly bullied and ridiculed by
james potter without reason we can
understand why snape was so often irked
by harry's uncanny appearance to his
father this wasn't helped by the fact
that he took the heart of the
professor's childhood best friend and
true love lily potter once we saw these
snippets of truth from the past we began
to have some sympathy for snape and hold
some compassion for him the final moment
he shares with harry asking him to take
his memory so he can finally understand
the truth is heartbreaking and allows us
to see how misunderstood and special a
wizard snape was this was also the only
moment the potions master snape was
honest with harry about the deep
remarkable connection they had the
professor may have been a man of few
words but his actions spoke volumes the
famous words you have your mother's eyes
are most powerfully said by snape in his
final moment a true testament to the
hero he was considering the journey of
the relationship between harry and the
professor this is definitely the
ultimate moment that made both audiences
and harry fall in love with snape it's
obvious to see that snape was never
actually a villain he was only ever
misunderstood was he cold and cruel at
times sure but he was also a master
manipulator of those who were evil a
brilliant potions master and a loyal
friend and guardian the only harm snape
can really be blamed for is dishonesty
by omission it took him years to tell
the truth but once he finally did he was
redeemed in harry's eyes as the
protector he had always been snape
taught us all an important lesson people
are not always who they seem to be we
were able to appreciate all the work
that snape did behind the scenes to
protect the beloved boy who lived
snape's storyline was integral to the
series and we don't think the harry
potter story would have been as
memorable without it the once villainous
potions master brought a deep complexity
and tenderness to the story that was
instrumental in making the series the
success it was and continues to be he
was
the bravest man i've ever known
what was the moment you fell in love
with snape let us know in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video give us
a like and don't forget to hit the
subscribe button for more content
[Music]